で これからどのように人生をね
まあ楽しく生きていられるかということについてお話しさせていただきます
まああの 楽しく生活したいという希望は当たり前のことで
その技を知らないんですね
どうすれば楽しいかと
そこは何か我々にお釈迦様から何か知恵を貸してくれるかなということで考えています
ある日 私は窓から外を見たところで
スズメの群れが毎日来るんですけどね
それで餌をあげるんですね
ご飯とか である日見ていたら
たくさん鳥たちが来て
見たところで餌はまいてないんですね
私は見ていて どうするんですかと
鳥たちはと見ていたら
何のことなく見たら餌がない
すぐ帰っちゃったんです
それだけの出来事なんですけど
私はそれを人間に当てはめてみたんです
人間だったらどうするんですかと
人間だったらよく希望があって
そこに行くんですよ 行ってそれダメだったらすごいブーブーと文句言いながら喧嘩します
で 例えば日本でも時々ありますけどね
収入がない 生活できない
大変状況悪い人々がいるとすると
そこでまあ政府関係か誰かが福祉関係の人々がそれなりにご飯とかいろんなものを毎日決まってる時間でお配りしているとします
そうすると毎日決まってる時間で食事やらいらんものもらいますからね
そこにその人々は集まるんです
そこである日突然何か訳があって
その配る側が来なかったとするとどうなるんですかというと
もらう側の人々が大騒ぎするんですよ
大騒ぎするんです 何ででしょうかと
時々もしかすると人をバカにするんじゃない？とかね
待たせるんじゃない？とかね
もう今日支給というんですか
しないんだったら 早くもって報告すればいいんではないかとかね
紙ぐらい一つ書いておけば我々わかるんではないかと
さんざん待たされてとかね
そうやって文句を言うんではないかなと
あるいはもっと気が強い人だったら喧嘩したり悪口言ったり批判したり
デモまでやるかもしれません
それは人間のやり方なんですね
私は見ていたスズメたちは何のことなく毎日餌をもらっているのに
来て見たら無い じゃあ帰ろう
それ以上何もなかったんですね
それでスズメたちにはおそらく苦しみがなかっただろうと思いますよ
餌がないことで じゃあ帰ろうと帰っただけですからね
人間にとってはそこにすごい苦しみがあるんです
そこら辺なんですね 問題は
人間というのはいらんことを考えるんじゃないんですかね
そのケースを見ても で
私は瞬間の出来事でしたけど
見ていたってもね 鳥たちは来た
帰った それだけ ほんの瞬間の出来事
人間はいらんことを考えて
あるべき姿とかあってはならない状況とかね
いろいろ決まり考えたりしてね
毎日支給するんだから毎日やるべきですよとかね
例えば 公の区役所とかどちらかで決まってる日で決まっている時間で
毎日食料の援助として何か配っているとしますね
そうすると規則作っちゃうんですね
もらう側も毎日やるんだったらちゃんとやるべきですよと
そうやっていらん規則
我々は作っちゃうんですね
あれは論理的じゃないんです
それによっていろんな苦しみが出来上がっちゃうんですね
だからまず考えるべきなのは
我々の心の中でいろいろ決まりが出来上がってしまって
その強引に人生をその決まりに合わせようとする
もし作った決まりは論理的なものでない場合は
かなりうまくいかない時はあります
それでいろんな苦しみがトラブルが生まれてくるんです
そのポイント 一応あまり説明いたしませんけど
覚えておいて あの このお釈迦様の教えを信仰している世界で
それほど経済的に 日本みたいに
ヨーロッパみたいに豊かということではないんだけど
よく見えることは みんなよく笑ってるんですよ
簡単に笑っちゃうんですね
笑顔ですね 笑うって言ったってもね
ほんの少々のことで笑ったり
ニコニコしたり 心の中で豊かに遊んでいるんですね
そこでこの豊かな国々も笑ったりしますけど
遊んだりしますけど それにはすごくお金がかかるんです
すごい決まりがあるんです
踊りにしたっても 何々やり方で踊るんだよと
それは厳密に守って踊りますね
そうするとなんか何か訓練やってることみたいで
そこに別に重要な楽しみがあるかどうか
ちょっとわからなくなっちゃうんですね
おしゃれをして楽しもうと思ったっても
やっぱり決まりがあります
流行がありますと ブランドの名前があって
そういうそれでないとかね
そうやっていろんな決まりが出来上がっちゃって
大変な苦痛になっちゃうんですよ
お金もかかっちゃうし
苦しみにもなりますね
それからいろんな遊ぶところだったら
時間決めてるんですね
1時間  2時間  3時間とかね
カラオケを歌おうと思ったっても
やっぱり何時間かと そこで時計を見ながら歌わなくちゃいけないんです
だから本当に なんとなく心にある
なんとなく この 何て言いますかね
この余裕というか 豊かさというかね
そこはなくなっているんですね
我々はビクビクして 時間に追われて
生活しているんですね
なんかいつでも私たちの人生っていうのは
この豊かな国々の場合はね
なんか後ろから誰かが
警察官みたいな誰かがね
機関銃を背中につけて脅しているような生活なんですね
その機関銃っていうのは
我々はもう何の意味もなく作っているありったけのいろんな決まり
奇策 規則 そういうものなんですね
それであの 結構苦しめるんではないかなと
だからといって 何も決まりも規則もなくて
野生みたいでいい加減で生活できるかというと
そうできるわけでもないんです
決まり 規則っていうのは動物にもありますからね
で いらんものはいらんと私はそれだけ言いたいんです
いらんものはいらないんだ
例えば今講演やってますから
喋ってますから 皆様方は 1 1そちらでお互いにお話ししないということは
一般的には決まりなんです
話を聞くということは決まりで
そのためにいらっしゃっているんだから
で それでみんなこういう服を着なくちゃいけないんだと
髪型はこのようにならなくてはならないと
座り方はこのように座らなくてはいけないと
そうやっていっぱい決まりが出ると
かなりストレスが溜まるんじゃないんですか
例えばこの法話に参加する場合は
こういう風な服を着なくちゃいけないと
という決まりがあったら
そこでストレス溜まっちゃうんです
座る時はこのように座ればいけないと
座らなきゃいけないと決まっちゃったり
で ストレス溜まっちゃう
ちょっと窮屈 苦しくなっちゃう
ではなくて 常識な当たり前の決まりだったら別に問題ない
真面目に話を聞きましょうと
お互いにいろいろいちいち喋ったりして
みんなに迷惑をかけないようにしましょうと
私は聞きたくないんだったら
自分だけ一人でこっそりと帰ればいいと
そういうことで この決まり
いろんな規則 決まりっていうのは
まあ論理的に それから必要な最低限でなければいけません
できれば減らさなくてはならないんです
なんでそういうことを言いますかというと
日本でこの仏教に興味ある方々は
まあすごいこの 誤解しているところがありますね
特にこの私たちの話をもうかなり聞きたがらないこともありまして
それからいろいろまああの
反対質問したりしますけどね
まあ合わないんだと このように
なんで合わないかというと
あなた方はものすごい厳しい戒律
いろんなことあるんですよと
でいて 仏教の勉強をしていないのに
日本語でこの三蔵経を訳しているんだからね
そういう戒律書とかね
読んだりするんですね
で さらにもう緊張して
ああ嫌だとかね と思ったりするんですね
いらんことをやってるんです
で 結構質問が来るんです
そういうふうに で 私もまあいらんことをやってるんだから
何か言いたいことはありますけどね
短い言葉で やっぱりまあ常識というものがありますから
言いにくいんですね だからまあどういうことかというと
戒律書ありますよ ものすごい
ファイブボリューム 本５冊なんです
結構大きいんです 注釈書も付け加えると
かなり膨大な量なんですけど
あれはなんで日本の方々が読むんですかと
テーラワーダの世界でも一般の人は読まないんです
仏教を知らない人は読むんですからね
それで仏教に文句を言うんです
そこで苦しみ作っちゃうんですね
で なんでかというと あれはお釈迦様は出家する人々のもう社会と社会人としてのしきたり
決まりとかね いろいろ学問的に整理して
その中の内容やら細かいところやら
守る方法とか破る方法とか
いろいろ法律学的にもう書いてるテキストで
それは自分に関係あるかないかと理解しようともしないで
すごい誤解して読んだりするんです
でお釈迦様に文句言おうとしてるんですね
で 仏教のお釈迦様の立場っていうのはそういう立場ではなくて
いらん規則 約束っていうのは人間にとっては大変なもう迷惑だと
だけど決まり作るならばいくらでも作られますよ
いくらでも作られます
この部屋出るとみんな先に左足出しなさいと
手を合掌して出かける場合は
合掌して左足で出かけなさいと
それぐらいの馬鹿げた決まり作ってみてください
かなりストレス溜まっちゃいますよ
忘れちゃったらなんかちょっとかっこ悪いし
やる時もなんかわけのわからないことやってるんだから気持ち悪いし
だからいらん規則作る場合はいくらでも作られます
それである日 サーリプッタ尊者というお釈迦様の第1番目の弟子の人が
で お釈迦様にこう聞いたんですね
この仏教というのは長い間人間の中で実践して守られるためには
どうすればいいんですかと
そうしたらお釈迦様が言ったのは
まあそれだったらこの適切なシステムが出来上がれば
人間がそのシステムの中で行動して
仏教を理解して実践して幸せになるんだと
それでサーリプッタ尊者
あ それであるならばお願いいたしますと
そういう規則をお作りになってくださいと
言ったら お釈迦様はどう答えたんですかというと
あんたちょっと待ちなさいと
余計な規則とかね 必要でないんだったら私は作りませんと
必要であったら その場でそれだけ作りますよと
だからお釈迦様っていうのはもうやっぱり人間
楽に楽しく生きることには邪魔したくなかったんです
決まりだらけの人生の中でなかなかうまくいかないんですね
まあそれで 出家したお坊さんたちが人に嘘をついてバレて大変なことになったら
あんた方は嘘をつくなと決まりを作るんです
そうすると守られます
なぜならば 嘘をついたところで大変なことになりましたと
やっぱりつかない方がいいと
ある日 あるお坊さんが何か托鉢に出たところで
その自分のよく知り合いの村なんです
そちらは祭りなんです
祭りだからその人々はお坊さんも知っているし
まあ今日はお坊さんみんな祭りやってるんだからね
みんなと仲良くやりましょうと
で みんなもう酒飲んで遊んでいるんですね
でお坊さんも座ってもらって
まあ一杯酒をあげて それから食べ物をあげて
まあお坊さんも何も知らないんだから
もう酒も飲んでご飯も食べておたりになったんです
すごい酔っ払って これ出家して人は酔っ払って他の人と同じくまあ悪口は言葉汚いわ
もう 見たらこれ他のお坊さんたちが大騒ぎになりました
なんということやってるんですか
これはもうけしからんなやり方
生き方良くない で お釈迦様のところに連れて行ったら
その人はもう倒れているんですね
酒飲みすぎて で お釈迦様の方に頭を入れて
まあ運んできたんです
運んで置いといたんです
そしたらこの人 何のことなくグルッと回ってお釈迦様の足を出して
まあ寝ているんです そしたらお釈迦様は他のお坊さんたちに
この人は普段も私に対してすごい失礼な態度を取りますかと
いえ そんなことはないんだよ
お釈迦様のこと大変尊敬している人ですよと
だったらなんで今日こんな調子ですかと
そしたら まあこいつは酒飲んで酔っ払っているんだから
だったら出家するものは酒一滴も飲むなと
禁止しますと そう 今まで酒飲んでいたわけでもないんですよ
誰も酒飲まなかったんだから
そういう決まり作る必要なかったんです
ある日突然 ある人がそんなことやったんだから
まあそういう決まりを作ったんです
まあそれからこの法律学的には問題が起きるんですよ
一体酒っていうのは何でしょうかと
それで酒という言葉に定義するんです
こういうこういう風に作る
こういうこういうものは酒ですよと
二種類ありまして あの
いろんなこの果物とかいろんなものを入れて
もうジュースみたいに作って
そこを発酵させてそのまま飲む酒と
それからそこを何と言いますか
温めて この蒸留と言うんで
なんて言葉わかりませんだけど
ディスティレーションと英語で言いますけどね
そこから取り出して別に作る
まあ二種類あると それだけじゃないんですね
また自然のいろいろ植物とか
インドではありましたからね
それを食べただけで頭がおかしくなっちゃうんです
ある一種のキノコもありましてね
これは南アメリカの方にもありますけどね
あれ食べたら頭がおかしくなるんです
そこであの そういう食べる人々がこの内緒で食べて
変なことを言ったりして
まあ変な現象を見えますから
そこで自分が神がかりだと
みんなに占ってあげると言って
いろんな自分の幻覚を語り始めるんです
人の顔を見ると 鬼の顔のように見えるかもしれませんが
その場合は その時はあなたには鬼が憑いてるんだと
除霊しなくちゃいけないとか
そうやっていろいろ信仰とかね
迷信とかいっぱいできます
お釈迦様それはもう そういうものも禁止だと言って
もう酒の定義をしているんです
そこで じゃあどれぐらい飲んだらという量の問題が出てくる
そこで仏教ではこれ決められませんよ
ある人は一升瓶ぐらい飲むと
酔っ払う可能性あります
ある人はカップ一杯飲んだところでもダメかもしれませんね
ある人は匂い嗅いだだけでも頭がおかしくなるかもしれません
だから量を決められませんね
法律的に そこでお釈迦様おっしゃったのは一滴もダメと
すごい論理的なんです
一滴もダメと そこで酒のまた種類がありまして
香りを嗅いで酔う酒とかね
で 体にあっちこっち塗ってもらって酔うものとか
酔うものだったらダメですよと
だからそういう風に見ると
酒一項目についても ものすごいきめ細かきいろんな種類がありますけど
そこを見て ああ この仏教は嫌だなとかね
言う人がアホであって
余計な苦しみ作るんであって
私たちにとってはそんなことは苦しみではなんでもないんです
すごい論理的で合理的でしっかりできているんだと
だから守りやすいんだと
それだけのことなんですね
で その例を言ったのは
このそのため酒のためでもなくて
この我々 この皆様は出家していないんだからね
出家者の出家のしきたりについて
全然もう困ったり悩んだりする必要ないんです
時々いるんですよ 私は結婚しないと悩んでるんですね
結婚していないんだと
よく悩んでくれるんです
大きな御世話ですけどね
だからそうやっていらんことを考えたり
いらん約束 決まりを作ったりして
で 悩んだりする人間の性格があります
だから皆様今日理解してほしいのは
我々は世の中でうまく生きているためには
いろいろ規則は必要ですが
それはいつでも最低限に
いつでも最低限に それから最低限に使っても
まあいらんようになってくると
それは取り消すという方向へ
できるだけ生き方自体を楽にした方がいいんです
そこで普通の人間の人生を見ると
なんで苦しみ なんで大変苦しんでるんですかというと
1番目 今 日本の社会のことを見てお話してますけど
別に皆様方にこれという問題ないのにも関わらず
まずみんな大変苦しんでいるのは
このあまりにもありすぎのこの決まりとしきたりと規則の量なんです
あまりにもありすぎ それまたどこかにテキストに書いているわけでもないんですけど
例えばお嫁さんだったらこうこうこうするべきですよ
旦那だったらこういう風にするべきですよとか
自分で決めて 時々両親たちが自分の子供大人になっても社会人なのに
またそれにあ こういうことをやっているんだ
これはどうですかとか
また悩んだり苦しんだりする
二十歳ももう取ってる
例えば自分の息子が息子も耳に穴開けちゃったら
お父さんが悩んだりしてケンカまでして
もういらんことです もう二十歳だから勝手にしろと
もう終わりと ですからまあ
やっぱりいらないことまで手を出したりして
結構苦しんだりする 時々聞くんですよ
何人か聞いたんですよ
なんか子供はあまりうまくいかないと
仕事にあまりつかなくても
ろくに仕事もしないし
これは私の業ではないかとかね
言って悩んだりするんです
あれはもういらないんですよ
そういう考え方は 時々こういう風にも言いますよ
あの これ戦争 自分の家の前の方々は何か悪いことをしたら
このひ孫か あるいはもう八代目でもあろうか
十代でも人であろうか
今苦しんでいるのは ご先祖様が何か悪いことをやったんだからと
それで悩んだりする だから非論理的なんですよ
例えば代の前の誰かのおじい様がね
その場合代前ぐらいっておじい様でひいおじい様なんでもないんでわかりませんだけど
言葉はね まあ年前年前の誰かが何か悪いことをしたんだからといって
今の人が苦しんでる その人を捕まってぶん殴るんですかね
あなたのせいで我々は苦しんでいるんだと
そういうふうに このいろんな決まり
我々は考え方の中で作って
作って 作ってきた で苦しんだりする
だから できるだけ合理的に論理的になればいいんじゃないんですかね
例えば 息子が仕事に行きたくないんだったら
よく見ると怠け者だと
だから この人が怠け者だから仕事に就かないんだと
勝手に苦しんでくださいと
それはもう私の業ですかと聞くのは
あまり意味がないんです
助けてあげるのは別なことで
怠け癖をなくすために
なくしてもらうためにね
なんとかするのは別なことで
悩みは何ですかと そういうふうな
日本の社会を見ると 文化もね
もうかなりすごい文化でしょうし
歴史もすごい長い間の歴史もあるし
そういうことで 私たちの人生には結構大変なゴミついてるんです
我々も日本の方々よりすごくニコニコと明るく振る舞うでしょう
例えばアメリカの人々は
アメリカ人なんかだ 若い人なんか僕を見ても
どこ初めて会ったで はいはい
どう元気？とすぐ聞くんです
時々遠くを よく私はもう先に行ってるんだけど
ものすごい大きい声で叫んで
もう元気ですかと あの明るさなんですかというと
やっぱりアメリカには歴史がないでしょう
だから決まり少ないんです
だから明るいんです 日本だったらそんなことは知らない人に叫んで
どう？あんたどこにお出かけですか？と聞かないんでしょうね
日本の場合は長い歴史文化がありますから
お出かけですかと聞くのは
こういうこういう人に聞くんであって
こういうこういう人には聞きませんという決まりがあるんです
そういう決まりがあるんだから
まあ少々我々の生き方は重くて硬いんですね
別に私はだからアメリカ人の真似しなさいと言ってるわけじゃないんです
ただ このシステムを説明しているだけ
だから私たちも何かこの過去から我々に強引に我々の生き方にこのもうつけられている決まり
規則 価値観について それは本当に論理的ですかと
その瞬間で本当に必要ですかと考えて行動すれば
楽ではないかなと思いますね
それで もう一つ違うポイントを考えてみましょう
人間なんで苦しむんでしょうかという
それはわかりやすい言葉で言えば
この我々にはこの文句言う癖がついているんです
文句言っちゃう まあ口では言わないかもしれませんよ
怖いんだから そういう性格があるんです
もし文句言う性格あるんだったら
まあ暗い 決して笑えないんです
文句を言ってどういうことかというと
皆様思っている文句と私が思っている文句は少々違うかもしれませんだけど
[咳]で文句言うっていうことは
自分が私たち 自分にとっては都合が悪いんですね
自分にとって都合が悪いんだから
相手に対して言うものなんですね
例えば今日は暑いんです
今日も本当にすごい暑いですねとかね
いつまでこれ続きますか？とかね
それ文句に入れ替えると
は嫌だと そこに苦しみが生まれてくるんです
例えば 人がちょっとうるさいとする
声が大きいとする その人に文句を言うんですね
あんた静かにしなさい
うるさいと 何も仕事できないんだと
それで苦しみが生まれてくる
その苦しみが文句を言ったんだからではなくて
この文句 頭の中で浮かぶ性格
一人二人で何か仕事をしている隣の人がかなりうるさい
かなり音を出す 自分には集中力なくなっちゃうとする
そうすると頭の中でこの人うるさいんだから
もうなかなか集中力できないんだ
仕事できないと思った途端
もう苦しみがもう生まれているんです
そこで口で文句を言うか言わないかということじゃないんです
ある人は口で言うかもしれません
静かにしなさいよと ある人はその自信もなくて
一言葉言ってやりたいんだけど
やっぱり言ったらさらに怒るかもしれませんし
やっぱりやっぱり言うべきじゃない
やっぱり言わなきゃこれ止まらないんだ
やっぱり言ったらまずいなとかね
そうやって言うべきか言ってはいけないか
また言うべきか またそうやって頭の中でさらにさらに文句続けるんですね
それで自分の人生 どんどんどんどん苦しく苦しくなってしまっちゃうんですね
そこで悪いのは こういう文句を言う性格がついちゃった人が 24時間言ってるんです
24時間文句を言ってるんです
頭の中で そういう人にとっては
どうどんな状況であろうとも
人生は苦しいんです そういう人は幸せにすることはもう誰にでもできます
頭を直せない限りはね
これ大変な問題 それは簡単な問題じゃないんですよ
文句の人生っていうのは
それからこのやり方ってものすごい微妙に難しいんです
例えば隣の人がすごくうるさいと
言ったらすごく明るく文句としてではなくて
自分が楽しくてね 心の中で喜びがあって
その人に言ってあげれば
もうちょっと静かにしたらね
楽しいのにとかね 私も楽なのにとかね
もうちょっと静かにしたら楽ですよとかね
あるいはニコニコとちょっとね
あんたちょっと邪魔ですけどね
やってること邪魔ですけど
向こうそれすぐわかるんで
この人すごく楽しく言ってくれるんだからね
それだけで問題解決するかもしれません
だからそれは文句言ってるわけじゃないんです
あんたうるさくうるさいでしょうと
静かにしなさいというのは文句であって
だから微妙なんです 心の状態なんです
で ものすごく人生幸せになりたければ
この我々は 第1に気をつけなくちゃいけないことは
この文句の人生なんです
理由は世の中で何一つも我々の希望通りにはいかないんです
何一つもいかないんです
気に入らないものはいっぱいあるんです
まあっきり言えばほとんど気に入らないものばっかりなんです
今日私はバスに乗ろうと思って
電車から降りてさっさとバス停に行ったんです
行ったらうまい具合にもうバスがあるんですよ
待っていて 二 三秒待たなくても
前に立っていた方々は乗るぐらいの時間なんですね
そこで私は財布を開けてみたんですね
二百円入れなくちゃいけないんだから
お金がない いわゆる細かいお金はないんです
そこであるものは全部計算してみたんだけど
二百円にはならないんですよ
せいぜい百円ぐらい 困ったもんでしょ
だからその場合 私の態度二つあります
なんて嫌ですかと この前の日あったこの細かいお金は全部もう何かあげて買い物しちゃったんです
その時も考えて それを全部あげちゃったら後で困るでしょうと思ったんだけど
まあいいやと その時それで払ってしまって
このバスも待っているし
次のバスはどれぐらいまた時間待たなくちゃいけないかわからないし
そこでもう細かいお金がない
それで一万円札は一枚ありました
それはバスで両替してくれない
それは私にいくらでも文句言うでしょうね
まあ一万円ぐらい両替してくれたってもね
何が変わるんですか？とか
また回数券とか何とかとか売ってるんだから
それからカードも売ってるんだから
五千円とかね お金あるはずなんですよ
だったらそれぐらいのことをね
両替してくれたってもいいんじゃないかと思ったりすることも可能なんです
それも事実だから そうすると
なんて不幸かと自分のことを思っちゃうんですね
バスに乗れないんだから
私はすぐ考えたのは これは文句を言うところじゃなくて
両替してもらうことと
言ったらまた店に行って
これちょっと両替してくれませんか？と言ったら
店にとってそれはかえって迷惑なんですね
買い物もしてないんだから
すぐ考えて まあ帰る時は何か買い物をしようかなと思っていたんです
必要な何かあって それを買わなくちゃいかないと
それは走って今買えばいいんだと
すぐ隣に店があったんだから
すぐそこに走ってきて
行ってさっさと上に上がって
そこはもう取って買って
そこでバスに乗ってきたんです
だからこのそこまでやらなくちゃいけないかと思っちゃうと文句な人生で
だったらこうやりましょうと
店にお願いして両替してもらうと
これちょっとやりにくいと思うんだったら
じゃあ必要なものを買っちゃおうと
それでそれを買ってバスに乗ってきましたけどね
だからこのいつでも状況っていうのはうまくピッタシ合うわけじゃないんです
時々私は手で二百円持っている時もありますよ
手で二百円持っていて
まあかなりせっかちみたいですけどね
持っているんだけど バスが来ない
待っていて 待ってて またすごい渋滞でとかね
そういう場合はあります
その時は二百円で何か遊んでいるんです
とにかくバスが来るまで
ですから この言いたかって言いたがっているのは
我々の人生の中で全て自分に都合よく回るということはないんです
回ったらおかしいぐらい物事はうまくいかない
そんなにうまくいかない
だから文句言っちゃったらもう大変なんです
切りがないんです だから知恵のある人は絶対周りの環境については一言葉文句言わない
自分の楽しみを壊さないんです
文句言ってみようと思ったら
もう切りがなくて切りがなくて
言いたければ何でも言えるんだからね
こちらからもう日が当たってて暑いとかね
ああ嫌だとかね いくらでも言えるんです
冷房は効きすぎやとかね
それで一人の人は冷房が効きすぎだから
もうもう何て言いますか
あの弱くしなさいと もう一人暑がりの人がもうすごい暑いんです
もうちょっと上げてくださいと
それで文句言っちゃうと喧嘩になるだけでしょうに
そうはうまくいかないんです
[背景音楽]暑がり屋の人はもうやっぱり冷房の温度はかなり下げて欲しがっちゃうし
そうでない人はもう弱くしてほしいし
で 合わないんですね ということで
我々の生きる 我々生きているこの環境ですか
その中でまあ全部ぴったし
ぴったしうまくいくということはありえない
だから楽しく生活したければ
こう考えるべきなんですね
一つもうまくいくわけじゃないんだと
私次第だと それはどう乗り越えて進むかということはね
それは私次第ですよと
見方次第ですよと 見方次第なんです
アプローチ それであの私は論理的にこういうことを言うんです
文句言う人が文句言うではなくて
よく覚えておいてください
この文句 頭に浮かぶ性格
批判したくなるなる性格
だから口で言う前に心で処理しなくちゃいけない
あ 私は批判したくなってるんだと
一言葉言いたくなってるんだと
感じますよ 心の中で何か嫌な気持ちが生まれてるんだから
何か一言葉言いたくなるんだから
それで自分も硬くなっちゃうんですよ
そういう文句言いたがる性格
嫌な性格生まれることに
私は論理的にこう説明するんですよ
そういう人々が大馬鹿者だと
それほど馬鹿が世の中でいないんだと
無知もいいところだと
まあそれもなんか文句のように聞こえるかもしれませんだけどね
一応これは個人個人の問題だから
自分のことだから 文句を言いたがる気持ちが生まれてくると
なんとなくこの なんて言いますか
モヤモヤと出てくると
ああ 大馬鹿もんだと自分が思った方がいいんです
なぜそう言いますかというと
まあこんな暑さでもう何もできるわけないんだよと文句の人がこの天気に文句言ってるんですよ
自分が暑さ嫌いだからといって
環境が涼しくなってくれますかね
だからそれは無知なんですよ
自分がなんかもう太陽もよりも宇宙を創った神様だと
神様というよりも創った神様いないんだけど
とにかくそういうふうに信じている人々いますからね
まあ一応神様だと思ってるんです
涼しくしなさいと 大雨だったら雨は止んでやめなさいというようなことなんです
なぜならば私は嫌だからと
だから他人に文句言う人が
私が嫌いだからやめなさいということを言ってるんです
だから私というものの起源というかね
私に好きなように世界が動いてくれますかね
そうは動かないんです
逆に文句言われるんです
我々はそんな偉い人でもないし
神様でもないし たとえ偉い人であろうとも
私が嫌だからやめなさい
私が嫌いだからやめなさい
なんとか言っちゃうと逆に文句言われるんです
ものすごく 私は父親だからといって子供に文句を言うと子供は聞かない
それでも ですから この
私は嫌いだから雨が降るなと
私は嫌いだから暑くなるなと
私は買い物をしたい時は店を開けておきなさいと
私は電車に乗りたい時
ちゃんと電車が来なさいと
という世界は成り立ちませんね
でも文句言う性格はそういう性格なんです
自分の都合通りに物事を変化しなさいよと物事に命令しているんです
それは病気 ですごい苦しみが生まれてくる
だからもう何と言いますか
無条件でやめるしか道がないんです
文句の性格 文句言いませんと
それでもう一つ そこにポイントがあります
例えば 時々家族とか会社とか
そういうところで すごい大胆な人がいるんですよ
強引で ものすごい大胆で
まあ自分の言いたい放題ことを言って
人に命令して ああしなさい
こうしなさいという感じで
あまりにも他の人々を圧倒されて潰されちゃって
まあ言う通りにみんなするかもしれません
家のお父さんがすごい怖いんだから
ちょっと失敗したら殺されるかもしれませんというぐらい
まあ今は日本ではそういうお父さんいませんだけどね
まあそれぐらい怖い性格だったらね
まあまだまだ日本以外はいろんな国々には結構いますよ
そういうお父さんのことはお母さんも怖いし
子供も怖いし ちょっと間違ったら何するか分からないと
そういう大胆 ものすごい強い人の場合は
周りはその人の機嫌計算しながら計算しながら生活します
つまり そういう性格っていうのは
本当はニセカキみたいなもんなんですよ
その強力な人が少々他のところに行ったりすると
みんなまた自分とやりたい放題になっちゃう
だから そういう人が自分の家族を
あるいは自分の会社をちゃんと管理したことにはならないんです
それは一つ もう一つ その大胆な人が自分の人生
何一つも理解しようとしないんです
だから何の勉強にもならないということ
あの 何回も聞いたことがありますけど
ずっと夫婦でいて あの
で 突然奥さんが旦那さんがもう会社も辞めて
家にいるようになったところで
突然じゃあ離婚しますと
私は それで男の人はびっくりして
どうすることもできて
何でしょうかと あなたに何の不安があるんですか？とかね
そこでまた文句言い始めるんですよ
それどういうことかというと
もしかするとその人は奥さんのこと
向こうのこと全然気にしないで
お茶入れなさいとかね
ご飯とか それ一言葉だけ言う性格でうまくいってるんだと錯覚しているんです
うまくいってるんだと
自分がお茶と言った途端
すぐお茶が来るならば
飯と言った途端ちゃんと用意してあるならば
お風呂に入るぞと言った途端
もうちゃんとお風呂の用意ができていると
うまくいっているんだと
それもおそらく男の人はすごく大胆過ぎで
人の話は聞かない性格で
それ奥さんもまあ十年
十五年 二十年 二十五年も我慢していて
恨みはどんどんどんどん
蓄積して 一旦その人も自由になるまで一応待ちますと
待ったところで失敗するんですね
じゃあ私はもう結婚して一人になりますと
男の人にも全くそれで理解できなくなっちゃうんですね
理解できなくなるだけではなくて
自分一人でまた生活もできないと
だから成長していないということなんですね
あまりにも強引 大胆で命令するだけの人だったら
その人はそのまんまで
止まったまんまになっちゃうんです
それはこの文句言う人生のすごい大変なこと
自分はものすごく他人に文句を言って他人を操っているということは
自分がどんどんどん底に陥っているということなんです
ですから 文句を言って相手を自分の希望通りに変える人が自分を変えてないんです
自分が原始状態まんまで
だから文句言う人生は良くないです
なぜならば 仏教というのはいつでも人間に言うのは
あなた方は生まれた状態のそのまま死ぬんじゃなくて
どんどんどんどん人格を完成して
進化して進化して 究極的なところで進化して死になさいと
だから仏教はいつでも謳っているのは進歩
進化することですよ わかりやすい言葉で
プログレスという まあパーリ語の専門用語いろいろありますけどね
プログレス 発展 進化 だから私たちはこの世の中で人間で生まれたならば
人間として発展しなくちゃいけないんです
進化しなくちゃいけないんですよ
昨日よりは今日は立派な人間にならなくちゃいけないんです
そういう生き方で生きていなくちゃいけない
今日やった失敗 今日やってはいけません
いつでも頭の中で昨日よりはいい人間になるんだぞと
ということをなければ
お釈迦様の教えの意味がなくなっちゃうんです
仏教はすっごい厳密にこの発展主義なんですよ
信仰主義じゃないんです
発展主義 そこでみんな発展だと思っても
視線破壊するんだけど
そんなことじゃなくて
何を発展するかというと
自分の人格をね 心を発展しなさいと
いつでも それでこの文句を言う人にとってはその発展はないんですね
発展はないんです だから我々の周りは一体気に入らないものだけで環境はできているんです
そこで自分がどのように行動するかということによって
毎日毎日自分の見方生き方発展していくんです
で 楽しいというかね 例えば私の財布を開けたところで
100円も細かいお金なかったと
全然損していないんです
それで時間としても それはうまく使ったんです
その状況は 気に入らない状況は
帰るときはまた店に行って
もう時間なくさなくてもいいんです
どうせ店に行ったらいろんないらんことも見るんだから
自分も時間なくなっちゃうんですよ
だから今日はそうじゃないんです
もう時間ないんだから
さっさと行って自分買いたいものはあったに決まってる
そこを取って買って買い
すぐ帰りましたから 時間も儲かっちゃうんですね
だからあの気に入らない出来事は
見方次第で一番いい状況に変わってしまったんです
それで私はその経験をそれからも生かせばいいんです
そういうわけで いつでも気に入らない環境の中にいることは決して悪いことじゃないんです
子供は言うことを聞かないとかね
旦那は旦那でいい加減だとかね
お金は収入は足りませんとかね
その上体もちょっと病気で弱いとかね
いろいろあるんじゃないんですか？もう気に入らないとそう
あれはとてもいいんです
幸せです あれすごい幸せなんです
なんで幸せかというと体が病気だから
なんで幸せかというと
もう旦那が全然家のことはもう知らんぷりと
子供はわがままで好き勝手やと
言うことを聞かないと
故に私は幸せですよというふうに言わなくちゃいけないんです
世の中はそう言わないでしょうに
だから私は不幸ですよと
いうのをみんなのやり方
仏教的なやり方じゃないんです
子供が仕事を見つかれば幸せなのにと
子供が早く結婚するならば幸せなのにとふうに言うんです
だから不幸だと自分が
それが一般的な生き方
そういう人は発展しません
なぜならば子供のせいだから
だから子供早く結婚してしなくちゃ
お母さんかお父さんが幸せにならないんですね
子供の奴隷 奥さんが旦那さんがまあもう遊んでばっかりですよと
お金無駄遣いしているんだと
だから大変苦しんでいるというお母さんが
やっぱり旦那の奴隷なんですね
独立していない 自由じゃないんです
ですから この不幸な出来事あるのは当たり前で
それでもって自分がどうやってそういうものにどんなアプローチで
うまく進むかと それで自分の知恵が発展していきます
人格が発展していきます
そこで幸せが生まれたそうです
だから今日論理的に言いたいポイントはそういうポイントなんです
世俗的な見方で見ると
不幸だらけの人生というならば
それは仏教から見れば
これは幸せですよと 例えば私は何回もある人に言ったんです
生まれた子供が障害だと
お母さんが悩むは悩むは
お父さんも悩むは悩む
もうキリがない で ある人が私に相談したんですよ
障害大変だと そしたら僕は怒ったんです
あんたね そんなに幸せなことないのに何言うんですかと
バカではないかと やってみなさいと
この子供の面倒 いかに幸せかと
いい加減にしなさいと怒ったんです
そこで後で言ったのは
そういう障害状態かといったらね
やっぱり子供長生きはできなくなります
とにかくいくら頑張っても
だからあんた方一生懸命頑張ってみなさい
子供はね どう見たってあんた方より先に死んじゃうし
死んだところでわかりますよと
死んだところで ものすごい穴が開けますよ
旦那さん方の人生には
家族を仲良くしてくれたのは
家族にものすごい充実感つけてくれたのは
すごい毎日にものすごい幸せ作ってくれたのはこの障害の子供ではないかと
その時わかるんだよと
だからその時わかっても遅いんだから
今日から頑張りなさいと
後で子供亡くなった話もその人から聞いたんだけど
やっぱりその人はその時随分納得していたんですね
やっぱり亡くなってすごく寂しいと
ですから そういうのは決して不幸な出来事でも
自分の業が悪いでも何でもないんです
ただバカだけなんです
そういう風に見ること自体が
今度私は飛行機に乗り遅れて
いろいろ計画もありまして
みんなシンガポールで一緒に旅をしようとしてたのに
で 頑張ったんです とにかくこの飛行機に入れてもらおうと思って
ギリギリのところまで
で 会社 飛行機会社のマネージャーが何か自分の友達二人ぐらい入れたくて
大はぶきんでそれ入れちゃって
もう私にもう今日はダメですよと
言ったらもう全部計画
スケジュールとかね もう全部もうむちゃくちゃなんですね
それは不幸な出来事 信頼までなくなる出来事
しょうがないと また帰って
次の飛行機っていうのは
またもう次の日の夜12時半ぐらいで
もう私は 3時ぐらいまで空港上にいて
次の飛行機にちゃんと予約して
しっかりと予約してもらって
文句言えないように向こう側に
で帰って また次の日 1日ありますよ
私にとって そこで自分にいつでもあちこち連れてくる
運転してくる若者がいて
そいつが言ったのはあんたすごく病気でしょうと
じゃあお医者さん行って探しますから
薬もらいましょうと 私はそんなもう 1 日でね
行って怒られるだけですよと
やめましょうと もういらんと
言って もう強引に連れて行って
いろいろ薬をもらったりして
で 今薬飲んでるんです
今日持ってるんです だからあれ
あの伝統的な薬で あの看板もない
何も誰も知らないところでコソコソとやってる
あの伝統的なね 親から代々伝わるところで
だからそういう秘伝みたいな薬いろいろもらって
もうすぐ飲んだその瞬間から体の調子がすぐ良くなっちゃって
今まで苦しがっていたのがバカみたい状態になってしまって
こんな簡単単純に体が元に戻るんだったらね
早くやっちゃえばよかったのにっていうぐらいなんですね
だから一つは私には大変なことになったんだけども
一つ考えて じゃあこの 1 日は何しますかと
こういうことしましょうと
で 違う方向で まあだから飛行機に乗るからってのは不幸ですか？幸福ですか？と
なんかどっちにすればいいんですかね
あれでよかったと言ったら
一緒にあの旅をしたいと思った人々には申し訳ないし
であれで大変まずかったと言ったっても
私にとっては別に悪かったわけではないし
だから人生ってのはそんなもんなんですよ
毎日何かもう大変なことに
大変な問題にぶつかるということは決して不幸ではないんです
だからこのすごく勉強していただきたいのは
我々は一旦人間に生まれたならば
まあわかりやすくこう言いましょう
バカに生まれたんだからバカで死ぬんじゃないんですよと
バカに生まれたのはしょうがないんだけど
死ぬ時は立派な人間で死んじゃうよと
ものすごい大きな人間になって
堂々たる人間になって死んじゃうよと
バカで生まれるのもしょうがない
もうもうもう過去のことだからね
もうあのリセットできません
これもなんか最近流行ってる言葉みたいんですけどね
人生のリセットできませんだから
で 死ぬ時は立派な人間で死ぬようにと
死ねるように だからこの
このテーマその通りに言うならば
最低の生活を最高に楽しく方法っていうのは
もう全くこの毎日 24時間我々にぶつかってくるありったけのこの気に入らないことについては
一つも文句はないということ
乗り越えちゃうと だからこの
なんていうのは歓迎してください
そういうものを 待っていてください
例えば子供の例で言うならば
子供はまあ 10歳ぐらいまではすごい可愛くて
言うことをよく聞いてくれて
すごい可愛いんです お母さんお腹がすいたとか
飛んでくるわ 作っているものはすごくおいしく食べるわ
そういうことをでやってると楽しいんだけど
もうあと 2年  3年で何やるかわからないんだと
だからそういうことを待っていると
ちゃんとその時間でちゃんと対応できるんです
だからボケちゃうんですよ
可愛い子供から助けられて
ありがたい ありがたいと
感謝 感謝だと あれは落とし穴なんですよ
わからないんだからね
子供っていうのは 学校に行ってどんな友達作るか
どんな環境 どういう風なことになるかわからないし
不良に走るかないかそんなのわからないし
勉強うまくいかないかってわからないしね
だからこの世俗的に不幸というものは待たなくちゃいけないんです
歓迎しなくちゃいけないんです
例えば世の中だったら
みんなこの幸せな老後とかね
健康で死ぬまでとかね
ああいういらんことを考えていらん苦しみを作るんですよ
ありえないこと 長生きもしたいし
で それでまたすごい健康でもいたいし
それでまた 40代ぐらいの若さでもいたくなっちゃうんです
で 頑張って頑張って 毎日苦しみだけ
長生きするとえらい寂しいんですよ
だから自分の子供見たって
もうおばあさんおじいちゃんだからね
孫なんか見たっても ひい孫なんか見だと全く別世界の別な宇宙から来た人間みたいなもんで文化が違うんです
やることも生きていることもさっぱりわからない
だからすごい寂しいんですよ
だからまあ そういうふうな理論的に将来を描くんではなくてね
今までは元気でしたけどね
これからどうなることはよくわからないんだと
もう体の中そろそろ癌も腫瘍でもね
まあできてるでしょ おそらく
そういうことを先に計算して待っていると
実際にそうなったってもどうってことないんです
ああ そうなったか ああ
なるほどというぐらいになるんです
だからがんですよとか何とか告知しちゃったら
みんな大変なことだと
なんかお医者さんがなんか犯罪を起こしたような感じで怒るんですけど
違うんですよ 告知してもらった方がいいんです
その準備を先にしておかないと
人は誰でもがんになる可能性あるし
人は誰でもボケる可能性あるし
人は誰でも寝たきりになる可能性あるし
ですから そういう場合は私はどのように乗り越えられるかと
あるいは自分の病気なんかはね
告知したところで まあ冷静な心でニコニコと
ああそうですか ああなるほどなるほど
というふうに聞こえる
聞こえますかと ある友達に聞いた話なんですけど
このあるお寺の有名なお寺の住職さんのお坊様が病院に行ったところで調べたところで
まあガンで まあということで
それで先生は普通は一般の人には言わない患者さんには
でもこの人は修行を積んでいて
まあ立派なお坊様で有名な人で
ですからかなり心ができているんだと思って言ったそうで
言ったところでもう大変なことになってしまったと
ものすごい混乱して慌てて
もう大変なことになって
もうどうしようもなくなってしまったと
という話は友達から聞いたんですけどね
だからそこもいくら有名なお寺の住職さんであろうとも
まあ馬鹿には変わりませんでしたからね
仏教は実践してなかったんだから
そんなことになっちゃうんですよ
だって常識だからね 人だから
人間だから そういうことだから
この人生楽しく生きるためには
我々には 毎日毎日 帰ってくる
この世俗的に悪いと不幸だと思うものは
まあどうぞ来てくださいと
来てみなさいという感じでいなくちゃいけないんです
来てみなさいという感じで行くと
何でもうまくいくんですよ
そのものごとうまくいくこともあるし
自分に対してはうまくやったぞという
なんかすごい充実感が出てくるんです
うまくやったぞと そのように
お釈迦様の教えっていうのは
人間にはこの 1 秒 1 秒進化するために
成長するために 発展するためにあるものなんです
だからあの仏教の論理的には
人生には何の意味もないんです
生きることには ただの幻覚なんですけど
それを悟りの世界で言っていることで
日常生活の中では 我々には生きる目的があるんです
それはやっぱり 1 秒単位で成長しなくちゃいけない
進化しなくちゃいけない
進歩しなくちゃいけない
より立派な精神を持っている人間にならなくてはならないと
だからそのポイントを終了するために
こういう言葉を言いたいんだけどね
世の中は変えるんではなくて
自分が変えれば簡単ですよということなんです
私の希望通りに世界を変えてみせるぞということでは全くヘリクツです
それだったらそこ それ自体不幸なんです
そのその各人が自分の希望通りに自分の我がまま原始状態なのに
心が その自分の希望通りに世界を変えようとすると
世界に現れるのはヒットラーみたいに
ムッソリーニみたいに人々だけなんです
世界変えてみせると そういう人がいれば幸せですかね
人類みんなヒットラーみたいですよと
ムッソリーニみたいんですよと
スターリンみたいんですよと
スターリンというのはスターリンですか
日本語で言えば いいんですかね
だからそうするとものすごい危ないんですよ
だから世界変えるんじゃなくて
自分を変えると ね  他の例で言えば
雨が降ってると 雨を止まってもらう
上がってもらうために工夫するんじゃなくて
傘を差すんですよ それで問題解決なんです
だから雨に向かってざまあみろと
それだけのことなんです
そこをいろいろ呪文唱えて雨を上がってもらおうと思ったって
ありえない話なんですね
時々いるでしょう？例えば末期だと言われたところで
残り人生はもう例えば今もうもう六十五歳かもしれませんよ
もう告知されたところで
あと半年ですよと言ったところで
あの半年で最高な人生生きると
そういう例とかね まあいろいろ新聞でもね
いろいろ雑誌でも読めるでしょうに
時々映画までいつも作ってるでしょうね
告知されちゃって 残りの短い日にちはすごい事実感があって
楽しく明るく生きていたんだと
だから良かったんだと
がんになって 昔ちょっと読んだ覚えがありますけど
リーダースダイジェストという雑誌ありますね
そちらで小さなこのページの上分のもないぐらい小さな記事があって
あるお母さんが書いた文章であの
自分ががんだと告知されたところで
あの すぐびっくりして
すぐすぐショック受けたんだと
ショック受けたんだけど
事実だからしょうがないんだと
次の聞いたのは あとどれぐらいありますか？と医者に聞いたんだと
聞いたら あとまあこれぐらいだと言われたんだと
そこで家に帰るまで考えたのは
この時間 私はどうすればいいんですかということだけですよ
そこで帰ってみんなに言ったんだと
私にはこれぐらいしか時間がないんだと
言って その日から毎日毎日生きることは想像できないほど楽しかった
幸せでしたと 怒りなんかはもう消えてしまったと
怒りっていうのは文句言う性格なんですよ
子供にも怒る 旦那に怒る
もう隣の人と怒る 犬に怒るとかね
全部消えてしまったと
怒るのはもったいないんだと
自分にはそんな時間ないんだから
そこでみんなとすごく仲良くして
ものすごいいい家族で
もう生活できたんですよとその人書いていたんだから
まあその時も死んでなかったでしょうね
死んだら書けませんから
だからそうやってすっごく明るくなってくると
雨が降ってると傘が差して傘を差せばいけるような感じで
体の中にがんがあっても生きていれるということなんです
時々あります がんっていうのはもう細胞だから
別に細菌でもなんでもないしね
細胞っていうのは割れ割れたり死んだりしますよ
例えば傷跡が傷ができたらね
すぐ治るでしょうに そんな感じで
それもあの細胞の働きで
がんでもね でけやったら人の態度が良ければね
自分勝手に死んでしまっちゃうんですからね
なぜならば 明るく生きることに精を出しちゃうと
元気な細胞を動き出しますよ
明るく楽しくということで仕事あるんだと
がん細胞に仕事ないでしょ
ただ増えるだけだから
他の細胞には大変な大事な仕事があるんですよ
皮膚の細胞にはその仕事がある
骨の細胞にはその仕事があります
心臓の細胞にも大事な仕事がありますよ
がん細胞には何の仕事もない
そこで人ががんになったら
暗い人はどうしますか？ああ
がんでどうしようか どうしようか
これ治してもらえませんか？とかね
あれ？なんて言いますか
いろいろ放射線やらね
いろんな方法で抗がん剤ででもこれ殺してもらえるんではないかとか
そんなことを考えちゃうと
がん細胞に仕事を与えたことになるんです
そこでがん細胞は なるほど
この人 私と戦っていると私にも仕事があるんだと立ち向かわなくてはならないという状態になります
そこは放っておいて 無視して
無視して 自分の普通の生き方
明るく元気に生きてきちゃうと
無視されちゃって仕事がなくて
そのまま自然死になっちゃうんです
だからそんなにそれほど思うほどの問題ではないと思いますけど
次にもう一つ我々にこの人生不幸になる原因がありまして
それは文句という一言葉でほとんどまとめちゃったんだけどね
まあもう言うことは残してないんです
この最低の人生は最高に楽しく生きる方法はね
それしかないんですけどね
で やっぱりまあ ちょっと伸ばしてもう一つポイント申し上げますけどね
あの時々人がいるでしょうね
もうちょっとあればいいなという
もう少々うまければいいんじゃないかという
もう少々 あれ気をつけてください
よくあるんじゃないんですか？もうちょっとあれば
もう少々は危険だと このもう少々ということは
まあまあもうちょっと説明しないとわからないんですね
例えば子供はよく頑張っているんだけど
あんたもうちょっと頑張ってもらえば
旦那さんが会社で頑張って仕事をして給料持ってくるんだけど
あんたもうちょっと給料上がってもらえばと
月あと 1万5000円
2万円ぐらい給料上がってもらえばと
そこで鏡で自分の体を見て
もうちょっとここら辺を何て言いますか
もうちょっと細かったらいいなとかね
ああいうもう少々なんです
あれは不幸でしょう どう考えたって
だから心からこのもう少々やめましょう
で 結構楽になります はい
これかなり悩んでますよ
その問題で もう少々の問題で
それでまた文句の病気も付いてきます
例えば旦那の給料も少々
まあ 2万円ぐらいあればね
ちゃんと家計を家計簿ですか
ちゃんともう成り立つのにと
そうなかなか 2万円給料上がってもらわないと
やっぱりこの人の才能がないんだとかね
頑張らないんだとかね
いろんなまあ文句の世界がまた始まっちゃうし
そのもう少々の人生っていうのは危険なところはこれずっと続くんです
だから不満で人生 過ぎてしまっちゃうんです
で まあこれはまあいろんなところで見えますよ
もう少々あればということ
だからもうちょっとあればうまくいくのにということだから
うまくいっていないということなんですね
不幸ということなんですね
不満ということなんですね
だからその病気でかなり人が苦しんでいるんです
かなり ものすごい苦しんで
ストレス溜まって もう倒れてしまって
死ぬところまでいっちゃうんです
時々過労死になる場合もあります
いくらお金あっても もう少々というのは病気で空いちゃうと
もう切りがなくなっちゃうんです
だからとっても危ないことなんです
そういうのはがんなんです
細胞のがんではなくて
心のがんなんです まあそれでね
癖がついてしまって このもう少々あっても
さらにもう少々あればということになるんです
そういうふうには世界ができているんです
はい 例えば 例えの話ですからね
あまり真剣にではなくて
その通りに聞いて 例えば 1万円ぐらいあればね
うまくいくのにと収入に
もうちょっと給料を上げてもらって
1万あればいいのにと思って
足らないという状況にいる
そこである日 やっぱり給料は 1万円上がったとします
その時の状況はもう変わっているんです
どういうふうに変わっているかというと
もう 1万では足らない条件なんです
いわゆる費用 費用というかね
もっと上がっているんです
それで旦那さんが喜んで
1万円給料上がったよと言っても
1万円では足りませんよと
今こういうこういうふうにもう子供にはもっとお金かかるんだと
食料の値段もこれぐらい高くなっているんだと
だから 1万円では足らないと
あの経済システムというのはそういうふうにできているんですよ
いつでも 例えば給料が上がっても
物価がもうちょっとそれよりちょっと上がっているんです
ですから 給料が上がっても
あんまり豊かになるということはないです
例えば物価 消費量というのは 3%上がったとする
それで給料は 5%ぐらい上がってもらえばありがたい話なんですけど
給料は大体 1. 5 とか 2%ぐらい上がりません
だから 1%は足らないんです
だから もう少々の不喜は決してもう少々あれば治るものではありません
決して治りません 世の中はそういうこと
例えばお母さんがね まあ忙しくて忙しくて
家のことでもうちょっと暇があればいいなと思ったりするんだけど
やがて暇が出ますよ その時はやることはないんです
年取ってますから そこでいろいろまあ踊り勉強しようとかね
言っても その時はやっぱりもう少々若かった方が良かったんではないかとという問題が出てきます
いつでもそんなふうなシステムなんです
で 子供の子供子育てに大変忙しくて
一人ばっかしでやっていて
旦那さんが全然協力してくれないと
それで心の中で旦那もうちょっと時間作って助けてくれるならばもう少々という論理ですよ
いいのにと旦那に言ったっても
まあどうしようもないんだと
忙しいんだと ということで
でまあそろそろまあ仕事にも余裕が出ますから
まあそこまでちょっと待ってくださいと
それでもう少々増すんでしょう
そこで旦那さんにやっぱり暇ができて
余裕ができて 家にいる時間長くなってくると
見てみなさい 子供はいないんです
その時は手のかかる 子供はそれで親に向かって大きな声ですけど
放っておいてくださいと自分のことと言う年なんです
そこでこの老夫婦はお互いに顔を見てじーっとせんべい食べながら得るしかなくなっちゃうんです
そこでまたもう少々の論理が成り立つでしょう
なんか何かあればいいなと
つまらないと そういうことだから
人生はそのふうにできていますから
もう少々あれば幸せなのにとという我々の心の考え方も不幸を作ることで
やめた方がいいです で
悪い例出しますけど このホームレスの人々いるんですね
で そういう人々はホームレスだからね
何もない方が楽なのに
もう少々あればいいという論理からは抜けてないんです
だからホームレスになってるんだからね
そこでまず段ボール箱を一つ二つ持ってきて
それで寝て それからその上に何かシートどこから持ってきて
まあそれで傘一つ拾ってきてとかね
この間見た人のところで傘まあ 20本以上あったんですけどね
で まああちこち忘れる傘とかね
まあいっぱいありますからね
それ全部拾ってくるんです
もうちょっとあればと
外に出ている人なんですけど
やっぱりこの雨が降ると
おそらく傘させて寝るだろうと思いますけど
私も頭の中で妄想してみたんですよ
人が寝ているとどのように傘させばいいかなと
なかなかそう浮かばないんですよ
方法は 頭の方に傘させちゃったら
こちらのお腹の方濡れちゃうし
そちらに傘も傘 1本必要になっちゃうし
そうすると間からまた水が漏れちゃいますから
そちらも何か必要になっちゃうし
それで足の方がまた濡れちゃうから
そちらにも傘 1本必要になっちゃうし
どう考えたってもいくらあっても足らないんです
あの問題解決するためには
だからその人がやっぱり傘 20個道をやってやって
またまた見つけたら拾うでしょうね
で 見るといっぱい品物を持ってるんですね
ああいうほとんどその拾ってくる品物っていうのは
壊れているもの 使い物にならないものとかね
あるこの橋の下で生活している人々を見たんだけど
この電気ポットとか あるんだけど
電気はどこから取るんでしょうかと聞きたいんだけど
ああなるのは別に買ってるわけじゃないかもしれません
いっぱいね まあゴミ捨てますから
まあ拾おうと思えばいくらでも拾えますし
別に壊れて捨てるわけでもないんだから
まあそれはまあ もしかすると電気さえあればお湯を沸かせるかもしれませんだけど
そういう人々は寒くているとこう考えるんでしょうね
やっぱりお茶でも飲めればいいなとかね
あったかいお茶でも飲めればいいなと
そうすると何とかで火を作って
ガスコンロでもいいし
まあなんとかでね まあお湯を沸かして飲めばいいんだけど
やっぱり電気ポットあった方が便利だと
で もう少々論理で言っちゃうんですね
そこで拾ってきます 冷蔵庫のはいいんだけど
橋の下だから別に電気コンセントはそこらにはないんです
あって 公の電気は盗むわけにもいきません
危ないし やってはなかったんだけどね
それだったらまたそこから追い出されるし
それから電圧はわからないんだから
この道路はあっちこっちある電圧は 100 100 ボルトだとわからないでしょ
200 ボルトも走ってますからね
だからそれは危険なんです
家庭用電気製品すべて 100 ボルトで
商業用なものは 230 ボルトで
だからボルト違う電気つけちゃったら
あれ焼けてしまうし危険でしょうし
でももう少々論理で あの人々は楽に生活しないで
いっぱいこの粗大ゴミ拾って拾って拾って拾って拾って生活しちゃう
だから引っ越しすると私が引っ越しすることと同じでしたけど
すごい大変なんです 荷物いっぱい
引っ越しというのは そういう人々も追い出されると他のところに引っ越ししなくちゃいけないんだから
ですから 妄想性の論理っていうのはそんなもの
風なもので どこにも見られる
人間の世界では 動物の世界では見られません
だから苦しみが少ないんです
動物には冷蔵庫はいりません
食べて残ったら置いておく
そのまま帰っちゃう じゃあ明日にそれ置きましょうっていうことはしません
まあカラスはしますけど
あれはすごい厳密に考えてカラスは食べ物は隠しておきますけどね
カラスは頭いいんだからね
あれするんですよ エサ探すのが面倒くさいんだと
だから餌ある時はいっぱいもらってきて
あっちこっち隠しておいて
ちゃんと時間にそこに行ってもう食べて遊ぶと
他のあまりね 動物はね
まあ一応そうやって蓄積する動物たちがいますけど
あれはすごい論理的にやってるんです
もう少々あれば楽しい
もう少しも楽しいと言って
破壊するところまではいかないんです
ですから 我々の人生はなぜ不幸かと
なぜそんな大変かというと
別に何も問題あるわけじゃないんです
頭が悪いんですね もうちょっとあればという
こんなくだらんことを頭に入っちゃうんですよ
もうちょっとあれば悪く悪くわけわけじゃなくて
その考え方が良くないんだと
今持っているものはどのように運営するかということは知恵であって
例えば 1ヶ月間は私にとっては 50万円必要だよと思って
もう少々もう少々じゃなくて
自分持っているお金は 20万円だと
だったら知恵を絞って 20万円でどのようにからくりすればということは知恵の世界なんです
で 昨日あの事務所いろいろお手伝いしてくれるこの大坂さんに一緒に買い物に行って
私は電車待っていたんだから
その時間の間で何か無駄話しようかなと
と思って無駄話したんだけど
どういう無駄話かというと
まあ二人で買い物に行ったんですね
実は私は今いらんものを買おうとしているんだと
で なんで買おうしているんですかというと
まあやっぱりいろいろ宣伝しているんだから
宣伝したってあれはいらんだと思ってますよと
でももう買おうとしているんだと
と言って 何かポイントをまた変えて
あの なんで買おうしてるんですかというと
まあお金あるんだから
でもそんなものを買って買って
どんどんどんどん今随分荷物増えてるんだと
いらんものばっかり選んで買うんだから
荷物増えるのはすごく嫌ですよと
それを知ってるのにまた買うんだと
だからもう結構バカもいいところだよと
いらんだったら買わなきゃいいのにと
昔は良かったと いらんものは買わなかったと
理由はお金も何もなかったんだと
だからこの本は必要な時は買うお金がなければ
人にちょっと貸してと言って貸してもらって
あの読むんだと だから本当はあの
それは必要な人が買ったところで
私もほんのちょっとあの貸してもらって
様子を見るだけです 様子を見たら
私はそれで納得しますからね
いらないんだと そこから論理を持っていって
あのお金がなければ 私はすぐその計画は中止しますと
いくら必要で必要であるものとも
物であろうとも 買うお金がなければ私は計画中止としますよと
お金だけは人から借りませんと
こういうものを買いたいんだけど
必要ですけど ちょっとお金貸してくれませんかと
来月貸して返せますよということは絶対しませんと
だから今まで一度も人からお金貸してちょうだいということは言ったことはないんだと
であるお金で全部とにかくやるんだと
どうしても必要なものだったら
人からちょっと貸してもらって使って
またお返しします そういうことで
人から全くお金借りることをしなかったということは
私にお金余分に必要ではなかったということや
ということは 十分満足しているということで
故に私はすごい金持ちだと
だからそういう風に考えておいてくださいと
もう冗談じゃないんだと言って威張って終わったんだけど
話を電車に乗って帰った
行ったんだけど それが私は結論として自分が金持ちだと
すごい余裕がある豊かな人だという理屈をつけたんだけど
それ言葉の遊びやっていたんだけど
その言葉の遊び 無駄話なんですけど
いつでも私はちゃんとした理屈は使っているんです
だから私は逆に言いたかったのは
人間の生き方 人間っていうのは持ってるお金より品物に心がいっちゃうんです
あれ欲しいと あれ欲しいって思ったところであ
お金がないんだと じゃあ分割払いで借金でお金借りて買いましょうと
そこは知恵ではありません
そういう人にとっては
いつでももう少々あれば幸せではないかという論理が成り立っちゃうんですね
だから人生は不幸になっちゃうんですよ
お金借りて借りて ひどい目に遭って
この中小企業とかね もうほとんど倒産しちゃうでしょうに
だからすごい恐ろしく
このそういう汚い商売
お金の商売をやってる人々はとにかく貸してあげて
その人を壊して 人生も壊して人を殺しちゃうんですね
何とか苦労して頑張って仕事をしている人々はみんな殺すことですよ
あれしているのは そういう人々も
まあただやっぱり借金すれば仕事もうまくいくんだということで
まあつい借りてしまっちゃいますけど
それでまた大変な落とし穴になってしまっちゃうんですね
だからこのもう少々あればということは捨ててしまえば
それほど早い勢いで この小さな小さなね
中小企業なんかは倒産しません
一番大事な人はそういう人々であって
たくさん仕事もするし
もうかなりでしょうしね
日本で見れば 本当にみんなかわいそうなんですね
なぜかというと この経済状態悪いということよりも
もうちょっとあればいいんじゃないかなと
万円ぐらいもう借りればうまくいくんだと思って
簡単に借りるところで借りてしまっちゃう
それで全部売り払わなくてはならない状態のそういう羽目になるという社会現象もありますね
そういうところまで人はなぜ苦労しますかというと
このもう少々あればうまくいくんだということ
ですから 知恵というのは自分が持っている豊かさで
持っている財産で どのようにそこを運営して前に進むかと
その過程で収入も財産も才能もいろんなものを増えてはいきますよ
増えてはいくんだけど
もうちょっとあればという概念はない
だから収入 才能 財産などなど増えるのは一向に構いませんだけど
悪いなのはもうちょっとあればというその方程式を入れることなんですね
そうするとマイナスにその分マイナスになってしまうんです
お金借りることになってしまっちゃうんです
無理をすることになってしまっちゃうんです
かなり人生無理するの
そういうところで時々みんな頑張りすぎ
働きすぎ場合もあるでしょ
それも例えば人の看病する
自分にはもう体力限界なんですけど
やっぱりもう少々ということで頑張ってしまっちゃって
自分も倒れてしまうと
仕事の場合でも やっぱり自分の能力限界なのに
もう少々と頑張っちゃう
それでもう全部なくなってしまっちゃう
会社の人々ももう社員たちが限界だとわかっているのに
もっと頑張れと もっと売り上げをもっと上がるようにしなさいと
それで結局逆効果で全部なくなっちゃうんです
だからこういう私は何かすごい冗談みたいに何か軽々く言うんだけど
そういうのは社会の小さいところから大きなところまでもう浸透している
もう悪いバイ菌みたいなものなのよ
この妄想の論理も だから人は無理をするのも
やり過ぎになるのも 頑張り過ぎになってすべて失うのも
この妄想論理を使っている論理というか
この妄想という病気で悩んでいるんだからなんですね
だからそのポイントから考えても
この知恵を絞れと 知恵を使いなさいと
家計 1ヶ月間の出費を出費を計算したら 5万円になるんだったらちょっと待てと
収入はいくらぐらいですか？と
頭がいい賢いというのは収入に合わせて
絞ることでしょうに だから
知恵のあるお母様方はちゃんとそうやっていろいろからくりするでしょ
収入はこれぐらいだと
それで全部割り当てて
塾にはこれぐらい 子供にはこれぐらい
私にはこれぐらい 旦那にはこれぐらい
食料にはこれぐらいとかね
ちゃんと割り当てて 綺麗にそれバランスシートを作る
それでうまくいくんです
妄想論理なければ もしそのお母様が賢いお母さんが文句言わない性格もあるならば
もう最高なんです ですから
我々の人生を不幸にする次のポイントとして
このもう少々あればいいということは
もう大変な危険なものだと
これで苦しみが生まれるということを理解していただきたいんです
で 時間はなくなりましたけど
またいっぱい言いたいことはありますけど
もう一つはそれほどこの大変大きなポイントではないんだけど
これは日本語の言葉はちょっとわかりませんだけど
英語で私はこのエイリアンネーションという言葉があります
エイリアンということを知ってますね
日本とアメリカだけ外国人にエイリアンと言うんですよ
英語わからないんです
アメリカ人が アメリカの真似で日本でも外国人にエイリアンと言うんです
あれ フォーリンナーズなんですけど
英語は エイリアンというのは宇宙人という意味なんです
だから我々の外国人登録証明書の英語で書いてあるのはエイリアンリーゼーション
宇宙人ではないんだけどね
最初はものすごく腹が立ったんですよ
それにエイリアンと書いてあって
何よこれだと 人をバカにするんじゃないんだと
人間なのに 見たら これ日本に文句言うところじゃなくて
アメリカで書いてるんですよ
エイリアンだと  そこは置いといて
言葉だけ借りましょう
エイリアンという言葉があります
それは一つの用語としてエイリアンというこの心理学的な状態あります
で そこをまたかなり不幸を作るんです
そう言って分からないのは何かエイリアンっていうのは日本語でどう言えばいいんでしょうかね
で  もっと分かりやすくします
例えば ある仲間の中にいるんですね
そこでいろんな人がいろんなことを喋ったり
いろんなことを言ったりする
なんか自分が関係ないんだと
自分と関係ないんだと
なんか別人のように考えたりする
その仲間に入らないんです
気に入らないんです やること
頭の中で違うことを考えるんです
みんなと一緒じゃないと
あのグループは気に入れませんと
それで自分を社会からなんか離れて別人やと思うこと
それはエイリアンなんですね
そういう人はもうとことん不幸なんです
友達は作れません 例えば子供の時でも
学校で言っても 他の人々とは自分が違うんだと
思っちゃうと仲間に溶けなくなっちゃうんです
なんでそういうことを言いますかというと
これも皆様にもそういう問題あります
あの 時々外国旅行なんかしちゃったら
なんか文句言って帰っちゃうでしょ
あれ エイリアンの病気なんですね
気に入らないんですよ
食べ物は気に入らない
環境は気に入らないと
人の性格気に入らない
当たり前ですよ 外国だから違うということは
そこで外国に行って 外国人と自分を比べて自分が日本人だと言って
そのたとえ 2 日間外国旅行したっても
その 2 日間そちらの人々と一緒に生活しなきゃいけないんですよ
その 2 日間 正真正銘の日本人になろうとする
それでエイリアン成り立って
問題トラブルばっかり作っちゃう
そこで外国から帰って日本に来たら
こちらでエイリアンになったりする
まあ日本でこうやるんだけど
向こうはそうじゃないんですよとか
こちらでまた同じ病気で
だから日本にいると自分が外国人だと錯覚する
いるんでしょうね 日本でも
自分なんか全部好き嫌いも好みも全て外国的でやることもなんだかんだも日本人と一緒にいるのに
そういう例えば全てアメリカ主義でやってる人がアメリカに行ったらもう最低で何一つも合わないんですよ
向こうの社会に アメリカでこうやってるんだ
ああやってるんだと話聞いてきて
こちらで真似しても 国へ行ってみたら全く違いますからね
まあ冗談で私はよく言いますけどね
アメリカに行ってホットコーヒー注文したっても馬鹿にされますよ
ホットコーヒーないんだから
アメリカンちょうだいと言ってアメリカンないんですよ
アメリカでは だから全く違いますよ
で こちらでいると こちらの仲間ではないと別人だと思った
私はあちらの人やと思ってしまって
そちらに行ったら違いますよと
そうやって私たちの心の中でいつでも大変な問題が起きちゃうんですね
それも知恵が足らない
まあまあいろいろ理由はいっぱいありますけど
これ大変よくあります
まあ例えば外国に行ったりする 1 週間の旅だと
やっぱり日本食食べようといきなり思ったりする
その国の食べ物を食べたところで
体に合わなくて お腹が壊したり
気持ちが悪くなったりしたならば
それは医学的なことでしょうがない
それだったら自分の体に慣れてる日本食を食べてもいいんです
そういうことでもなく
外国の今まで食べたことがないいろいろ食べ物やら味付けやらところで
いや 私はこんなもん食う人じゃないんだとエイリアンして
そこで日本料理ところに行く
行ったところ それは外国人が苦労して日本の真似しているだけであって
寿司作ります 作ってますよ
うどんラーメンもありますけど
それは日本で作ってる寿司とうどんとラーメンとは似てるわけじゃないんです
そこに行って高いお金払って食べてみたところで
あれ何か違うんだと 言ってまた帰ってそちらにも文句言って帰っちゃうんですね
日本食屋閉じろって言ったってもね
あのラーメンのスープは何ですかとかね
寿司を作ってあったんだけど
あの米はね あのご飯は
あの魚の切り方なんだと
あれはと 例えばシンガポールでも寿司とかありますけど
ちょっとバカでかいんですよ
刺身とかね だからあの
見たらまあ日本で見てる人には食べたくなる
だから行くなと言いたいんですよ
だからシンガポールで刺身やら寿司やら売ってるんだから
シンガポール人が食べた方がいいんです
そうすると あ 今日は我々は日本食食べたんだと
例えば日本でいて中華料理食べてるでしょ？イタリア料理
フランス料理 あれはもう本当に中華料理でしょうかね
インド料理も知ってますからね
私は知ってますからね
インド料理 私も食べますけど
あれは本当のところインド料理ではなくて
インド料理の日本語バージョンなんです
日本語ではなくて日本バージョンなんです
中華料理も同じなんです
日本にある中華料理は中華料理の日本バージョンあって
中国バージョンではないんです
もし中国バージョンこちらで商売したら誰も食べないんです
インド料理もインド人が食べるように作ったら誰も食べないんです
だから シンガポールで日本料理屋でやってる寿司やら刺身やら
シンガポール人にとってはもうすごい
ああ これは日本料理だと
健康にいいんだと言って食べてもいいんだけど
日本人が行ったって文句言うのは当たり前なんです
だからアリエイネーションという病気がなっちゃうと
そうやってどこに行ってもすごい不満が生じてくる
納得いけなくなっちゃうんです
時々私のところの瞑想に来る場合は
私はヴィパッサナー瞑想法を教えるんだけど
座禅の真似をする で 私にまあどういう人は
まあ私はもうよく座禅やってるんだからと言って威張っちゃうんですね
私は気に入らないんですよ
私の気持ちから言えば
座禅やりたければ禅道場に行きなさいと
なんであんたこっち来るんですかと
あれはアリエイネーションの病気で何一つも見抜けないんです
その方々は なぜならば
禅道場で禅をなさってみて不満が募って
なんだこれは気に入らないんだと
このやり方とかね わからないんだと
気に入らないんだと じゃあテーラワーダのヴィパッサナーでもやってみようかなと
で 来る 来たところで なんだこれはなんかいい加減ではないかと
しっかりピシピシと言わないんだと言って座禅の真似をする
それでこちらでテーラワーダの方法を教えてもらったところで
禅道場に行ってそちらでトラブルを作る
いえ 瞑想はそういうふうにやるものじゃないんだとか
もうトラブルだらけなんです
でしょ？そういう風になっちゃうんです
だからこのアリエイネーションという病気っていうのは
人間にはもうあるならば
それをもう治した方がいいんですよ
例えば たとえ私が坊主であろうとも
周りに子供たちが集めたら
俺が坊主だからという感じで威張っちゃうとうまくいかないんですよ
それでその時は子供の世界に入って子供と一緒に溶けると
溶けたんだからと私の人格が死んだわけじゃないんです
時々子供と遊び相手になってきたところで
かなり苦労させますよ
子供も で なんかくだらんガラクタなんかこれちゃんと持っていてとかね
はいはい わかりましたと持ってるんだけど
まああまり大したことじゃないんだから
ちょっと気が緩んだりするとダメですよ
そんなことしたらとか
ちゃんとこういう風に持っていかなきゃいけないんですよと言われたりする
そこで大人になって説教するんじゃはいはい
わかりました わかりましたとかね
子供はだいたいこの何て言いますか
いろいろイメージを作って遊んだりするでしょ
例えばもう葉っぱとかなんとか作ったものは
これはワンちゃんですよと抱っこしてくださいと言ったら
ちゃんとワンちゃん抱っこしてるような感じで抱っこしてあげないと怒られますよ
子供に 落としたりしちゃうと
すごい怒られます だからその時は子供はなんとかのもう何か作ったものを持ってきて
これはワンちゃんですよ
だからちゃんと散歩させてくださいよと言っちゃったら
もう照夫さん散歩言って散歩させましたよと言ってあげないと
なんだこれ もう散歩する必要ないでしょうに
生きてるものじゃないんですよと言うべきではありません
あの世界では  [背景音楽]それで
そのその社会環境でそこに合わせて生活する
で 私はあんまりこの私にべったりと人はついてはいけませんと思っているのは
人はそういうわけなんです
私の生き方がわからなくなっちゃうんです
なぜかというと この瞑想を教えるときはきちんと瞑想を教える
説法する時は説法する
論理的にしゃべるなら論理的に言っちゃうと
ただ 日常生活のまあふざけてまあいい話をそれもやります
私がどっちかというと
もうどっちでもないんですけど
で まあ子供と遊ぶことあったら
まあそれもやります そこを見て把握しようと
どんな方ですかと 今度型っていうのは形の人ですか？と見たら見にくいかもしれません
とにかくAlienationの人だったらもうどちらにも合わない
私が言いたいのは そのその場に合うようにしましょうと
アフリカに行ったら日本って綺麗だな
山がいっぱいあって 自然があって
緑があっていいなと言うと幸せがないんですよ
そこでアフリカに行って
そちらに やっぱり砂漠だらけで
もう水もないし もう大変だとかね Alienation
になってしまって 日本に来たらやっぱり秋田っていいですね
広々してどこを見ても大地
大地で これは窮屈だよと
こちらにも だからどこへ行っても
その人にとっては幸せではありません
それはちょっとした心の問題なんです
たとえ20歳ぐらいの若い男の人であろうか
あるおばあちゃんのグループに捕まってみたら
おばあちゃんたちに合わせればいいんです
すごい楽なんです だから
そのその環境によって合わせるということを
また微妙でバカみたく真似することでもなく
このぶつからないようにする
例えば 70歳のおばあちゃんが25 6
歳の若者のグループに入ったりする
おばあちゃんが苦労して苦労して若者に合わせようとしても
それは無理なんです それはしない方がいいんです
その場合は合わせるのではなくて
何か違うものがあるんですよ
ぶつからないようにする
例えば もう若い人々の世界違いますから
もうわけもわからないことを言ったりすると
それはどういうことですかねとかね
聞いたりとか ああそうですかそうですか
なるほどとかね そうやって理解してあげたりとかね
教えてもらったりとかね
あんた方はそんなことをやってるんですか
なるほどとかね それぐらいでいいんです
それぐらいでこのAlienationの問題がなくなった
なくなっちゃうんです
そこで若者は優しいおばあちゃまだよと向こうは思ってくれる
若者は激しく踊ったりしているんだから
私も一緒ということで
おばあちゃんが遊んじゃったら
それは気持ち悪いし 若者とおばあちゃんが上等
ごめんなさいんですけど言って別に離れる可能性もあります
会うっていうことは 若者は踊っているんだと
おばあちゃまが まあまあ
あんた方はね いろいろ散らかしているんだから
ちょっと片付けてあげたりするとかね
そうやってその合う合わせることなんですね
全く真似することではないんです
ぶつからないようにすること
ですから Alienation
の代わりにAlienation日本語で何と言えばいいんですかね
えっ？まあなんかそんな似てるね
そういうふうな言葉でしょうね
英語だったらね エイリアンという言葉でAlienationですけど
エイリアンだからね やっぱりこれ
それもなくなっちゃうと
我々のはどんな悪い環境でも生活できるんですよ
楽しく 遭難したっても問題ないんです
だから この例えば地震
どこかでね 人が何か埋め込まれちゃって
2日  3日  4日  1週間ぐらいもうそれでまたまた救出されたんだけど
やっぱり 上からずっと水をかけていたみたいですね
そこで自分のいるところで水一滴一滴落ちるんで
その人はじっとその一滴で飲みながら
あのガレキを放り出して
人 見つかるまでもう頑張ったんです
だからすぐその環境に合わせちゃうと
だからそうやってすごい不幸になっても
地震が起きて生き埋めになっても
その環境の中でどうすればいいかっていうね
知恵が出てくるんですね
エリート意識の人は全くもう変なことを考えちゃうんですよ
アフリカに行って寿司食べたくなっちゃうとかね
サバって魚もお湯もないのに
とか それぐらいのもう全くもうありえないことを考えてしまっちゃうんですね
日本に行けたら もういっぱいあるんだから面白くないと
というふうに思ったりする
で 例えばこの 第3世界の国
どこかに行ったとする
そこで病気になったとします
それで病気になったら
そこら辺のもう医者に頼んで
まあそれなりの薬もらっちゃえばいいんですよ
そこですごい立派な病院でなければいけませんとかね
医者はレントゲンを撮らなくちゃいけないんだとかね
いろいろもう検査しなくちゃいけないんだとかね
まあそんなことではなくて
ハエが飛んでるんだと
これは治療上ですかとかね
その場合は他の選択は何もない
大変なところで自分が病気になった
そこら辺にいる それなりの治療できる人から何とかできないかと聞いてもらって
その場でその問題を解決しなくちゃいけない
後で日本に帰ったらちゃんと治療できますよという具合にまた帰ってやりますから
そういうふうにこの環境にとぶつからないように
人々とぶつからないように
いつでも自分を調整するような柔軟性
持つと まあまあ それで話は終了しますが
まあ大体楽しく生きるためには
我々にはお金あったら楽しいということは
今日の話には合わない
お金があったら人生楽しいというならば
世の中の人は楽しくなりません
こんな少ない 健康だったら私は幸せだという人は幸せになりません
なぜならば 健康な人間というのは数少ない
抜群に頭が良ければ私は幸せですよというならば
その幸せ人は幸せになりません
そんな頭に頭が良い人というのは少ないんです
美しくいれば幸せだと思ったら
人は幸せになりません
美しい人っていうのは少ないんです
我々はこの少ない世の中で
稀なものを見て あれやれば幸せは
これやれば幸せだという
全く屁理屈使ってるんです
だから稀なものあれば幸せではなくて
あり過ぎなもので幸せをつかまえなくちゃいけないんです
何があり過ぎかということ
普通に不幸というものはあり過ぎなんです
宝くじ当たったら幸せだというとありえない話でしょうね
一番あり得るのは外れることでしょうね
だから人間の幸せの概念というのは
ありえないことあったら幸せだという
全くおかしい話なんです
具体的じゃないんです
健康であれば 美しくでいれば
家庭はもう全くもう水のように幸せであれば平和とか
お金があればとか 権力あればとか
人気あればとか なかなかありえないものばっかり希望する
だから完全に不幸なんですよ
豊かなのに あのお知らせも書いてあったんですよ
日本人には文句言うものは何もないんですけど
あるものはほとんどもうあり過ぎぐらい揃っているのに
心に幸せは見つからない
それは考え方おかしいんだから
ありえないものを希望する
だから不幸なんですね
ですから この 幸せを ないものから作るんじゃなくて
いっぱいあるものから作った方が確実なんです
そういうことだから こういうポイントはずっと言ってきたんです
あるものから幸せを作ろうと
で 肯定的な言えば やっぱりいつでも我々実践しているこの慈しみの気持ち
それ肯定的なポイントだけなんですけど
慈しみの気持ちを育てる優しさ
人に攻撃するんじゃなくて
生命に攻撃するんじゃなくて
みんな幸せであってほしいと
気持ちを育てる それでぶつかること
文句言えることも消えてしまう
それからこのもう一つ
何か自分でも役に立つこと
何か一つでもいいんだから選んでください
それ自分にできることを選ぶんです
その場合でも何か自分にできること
簡単に人に役に立つこと
人だけでもなくて まあ他の生命でもどっちでもいいんです
だから不思議なことは
どんな生命にもやるべきことはあるんですよ
生きている環境にしてあげることは必ずあるんです
それを早く見つけてほしい
自分が何をすればいいかと
それもあの宝くじの論理でいくんじゃなくて
自分が何を持っているか
何ができるかという 自分にできることの何かを
社会のために 人のために使うと
使用すると そうやって他人に何かを役に立つ
何でもいいんです 何かを役に立つようにする
掃除できれば掃除だけでもいいんです
なんとか何でもいいんです
人の役に立つことをする
そうすると生きがいというものが出てきて
楽しく生きていられるんです
まあそれからまあできるだけこのもうちょっとあればの論理の反対
少なければいいと というこの少ない方がありがたがること
ある所欲ですね 買い物をする時でも
やっぱり同じ品物はいろんな値段で売っている場合はね
似ているものはね まあ簡単に平気で一番高いものを買ってしまっちゃうんじゃなくて
見て まあまあこれぐらいのことでいいんだと
やってこの少なくするんですね
でもまあ他の言葉で言えば
このやりたいこといっぱいあるんじゃなくて
やりたいことは少なくしておく
ですから やりたいことはまずいっぱいあるかもしれませんだけど
あ これもできない これもできない
これもできない これもできないとできないものを全部もう削除して
できるだけできるだけ少なく
少なくして あ まあこれぐらいのことをやりたいんだと
これはできるんだということになっちゃうんですね
で それであのかなり楽になっちゃうんです
それから常に喜んで生活する
いつでも喜んで で 何でも喜ぶ人でも何でも喜びますよ
だから 例えば皆様方 これ早くこの話を終わって
他の何かしようと思ったりすると
それで話が延々と伸びちゃいますから
これ普通だったらもう腹が立ってしまっちゃいますね
そういう不幸な出来事も喜びに変わってしまっちゃう
話はかなり伸びてしまっちゃったんだと
だから買い物したかったんだけど
あれはやめたと 友達は買い物したんですかと
家に帰ってあれ買ってきたんですかと
そしたら あれ残念なことではなくて
あれ威張って言うんです
実はできなかったんですよ
話は伸びて伸びて伸びて伸びて切りがなくて
言っていて だから私は買い物しなかったんだと
大体もう不幸なことやら何のことか
これ冗談に楽しみ 楽しみに変えればいいんです
それも心の問題で 別に物質はお金いりませんしね
それにはね 満員電車に乗ったところで
何かカバンは電車に挟まれたらね
今は電車動けませんだけど
服ぐらいは電車に挟まれたら動くんですね
ドアに そうやって言っちゃうと
それは大変だ なんとでしょうかということじゃなくて
かえってこれ喜んじゃうんですね
よかったと 倒れなかったんだと
出かけても ぎっしりと掴まれてやったんだからと
そういう風に このどんな状況でも
まあ冗談に回しちゃう
喜びに回してしまっちゃう
それが一つの心の訓練になります
だから 何でも喜びに回すと楽しみに回すんだということでも幸せが成り立つんです
それから心の明るさですね
軽々と すごい気楽に物事をあんまり真剣にもう執着して取るんではなくて
まあ軽々と明るく物事をやってみようと
というぐらいのことで
どんな人生でも大変楽な楽しい人生になります
で またいろいろややこしいポイントいくつありますけど
もう一つポイントだけ言いますけど
人は信じることと人は信じないこと
両方合わせてやらなくちゃいけないんです
人は信じないとものすごく不幸なんですよ
だからって人を信じてしまったらとんでもないことになるんです
どうすればいいんですかね
そこら辺も考えておくことなんですね
だから これちょっと言葉で言いにくいことなんですけど
人は疑ったりするんでもないんだけど
人いうことをバカみたくはい信じてやりますということでもよくないんです
そこら辺で中道という
だからわかりやすく言えば
人は信じて信じないでくださいということしか言いませんだけど
で 信じていたのにということにはなりません
あなたのことを信じてたのにとかね
まあ信じてはいたんだけど
そういうこともあり得るんだと
ということで いわゆる迷信的に人を信じるんでもない
そこはでも合理性を守って
だからといってどんな人も疑ってはいけません
人は疑わないんだけど
バカみたく非合理的に信じるということもしませんと
というこの頭のちょっとした鋭さ
そういうことで人生は大変楽になるだろうと思います
ありがとうございます
[拍手]